all right a lot of breaking news about
the deep state this week including
explosive developments in the case of
Michael Flynn in his case and a lot of
major questions still looming large such
as when are we got to get the inspector
general's report on files abuse and is
this premeditated fraud on the court
were they illegally obtained joining us
now for reaction the chairman of the
Senate Judiciary Committee that would be
Senator Lindsey Graham senator we know
that as Greg just said four separate
times the FBI and DOJ will warn not to
use the dirty dossier you and Senator
Grassley came out with a memo that said
the bulk of the application was the
dirty unverified dossier the Russian
dossier Hillary paid for so the question
then is does that mean it was
premeditated fraud on the court and that
those warrants were illegally obtained
to me I'm not that I'm not the AG but to
me it seems like slam dunk easy case
boom well we'll see what mr. Horwitz
says but I can promise you this Shaun
the Senate Judiciary Committee will call
mr. Horowitz and he will testify under
oath about his report and we're going to
pursue this in a transparent fashion
we're going to declassify as much as we
can including the FISA warrant
applications I'm going to give you all
the information that was in the system
about how suspicious people were of
Christopher Steele how biased he was let
you read it for it for yourself
transparency and accountability is my
goal well kind of ducked my question
well I'm not trying to put a lot of
pressure on you here I don't know what
he's gonna say okay do you you're a
lawyer you're smart we're a senator you
followed this case as closely as I have
do you believe that it is overwhelming
and incontrovertible and the evidence
shows one thing pre-meditated fraud on a
FISA Court and warrants obtained
illegally denying one American citizens
his constitutional rights and denying
the president well candidate then
president elect and president his
constitutional rights that allowed
spying on him well here's what I believe
without any doubt that the dossier is
unfair vide
verified to this day it's a bunch of
garbage and that the author of the
dossier was on the payroll of the
Democratic Party
he was unreliable and that the system
had a lot of notice about his bias they
obtained a warrant on four different
occasions and it will be held to account
for that but mr. Durham will make a
decision as to who to prosecute if any
one and my goal is to explain to you and
the American public how the system
failed and make sure it never happens
again and I will also make sure that
Rosenstein and McCabe are called before
the committee to explain what happened
regarding conversations about
wiretapping President Trump after the
election
to me that is a very chilling moment in
American history to have a conversation
between the acting Attorney General the
acting FBI chief about wiretapping the
president of the United States that was
beyond shocking to me thank goodness for
judicial watch to do a great job when
John Solomon and Greg and Sarah I got
look I can't mention everybody Joe and
Victoria there was someone's gonna get
mad at me let me ask you I do appreciate
the fact senator that you're gonna you
have said you will ask about whether
there was a rigged investigation into
Hillary's right now you will find out if
the counterintelligence investigation
started in the White House a Barack
Obama what did he know what did he know
it you will find that out too yeah I
wanna what let's just look at the moving
parts here I want to find out was the
Clinton email investigation basically
rigged in her favor because a political
bias was the counterintelligence
investigation opened up against
Papadopoulos based on a desire to get
into the Trump campaign versus
protecting the Trump campaign from
Russian interference when there was
really no evidence of Russian
interference was the FISA warrant
obtained based on fraud was the
certification the court basically
perjury and did after the election did
they surveilled the Trump campaign
improperly if there was no reason to
believe that Michael Flynn was a Russian
agent why the hell did they talk to him
anyway about his conversations the
transition team how do you feel about
the deputy FBI director say oh no you
don't need a lawyer when Flint asked
them when he didn't need a lawyer and
what did you think about the FBI
director Comey super Patriot called me
when he said yeah I sent them in anyway
I took advantage of the casts I I put
all procedure aside I wouldn't do that
in the Obama Bush administration sorry
but yeah I did that I just I kind of
screwed of 33 year military vet well so
we're talking about 9/11 I I served with
general Flynn in Afghanistan when I was
a reservist he's a patriot and here's
the question for me if all the things
you said are true what who should be
held accountable did they trick general
Flynn did they have a reasonable belief
that he was working with the Russians
and why would the existing
administration surveil the incoming
administration about conversations about
changing policy and I'd like to know if
they outsource the subcontracted spying
to our or Western intelligence friends
let me see I'm just guessing Great
Britain Italy Australia Canada right
pretty good the best let me just fill
his links there did the person who
informed Papadopoulos that clinton ii
emails had been hacked were there's well
there's somebody known to be working
with us was there any evidence at all
that Papadopoulos was working with the
Russians I'm not seeing one piece of
evidence to suggest here's working with
the Russians I'd like to see if there's
a skull pretoria but it's in that case
but again I'm so stupid what would I
have no knowledge of any of this you
know but our 911 deny good job of
explaining the American people the way
you see what we are you will see at the
end of this show something people are
going to want a DVR and sent to their
friends